>> We like to have a lot of fun
here too, and since you're on
the Actor's Corner,
we have to corner you.
>> Okay.
>> So, Becky Holt,
the spotlight is on you.
>> Uh...
Well...can you cut?
Am I--do you want me to do
my--let me think--
>> Whatever you're feeling
in your heart to do.
>> Whatever I'm feeling
in my heart.
Rebecca, I know you're my
best friend, and you've had
breast cancer.
I just really need you
to come with me,
and we can get this done.
You're awesome.
I know it's gonna be difficult.
We've had a lot
of ups and downs together.
I can be your manager.
I can bring you back.
I can really help you.
You're a survivor.
We can do this show.
It's gonna be called
"The Bubble."
We're gonna have a lot
of awesome actors in it.
I know you can do it.
Let me--just come with me,
and I can help you.
>> Encouraging.
She really disappears
into her character.
What kind of monster of a host
just hangs someone
out to dry like that?
Can you imagine anything
more uncomfortable?
Well, we like to have a little
fun on this show, too,
and since you're at the
"Tosh.0" taping,
I have to corner you.
So, audience member,
the spotlight is on you.
>> Encouraging.
Now the spotlight is on you.
>> [laughs]
Can we go home yet?
>> Now the spotlight is on you.
Whatever you're feeling
in your heart to do.
>> Discouraging?
>> Encouraging.
Now the spotlight is on you.
>> I could host
this show better.
>> Encouraging.
Encouraging.
Now the spotlight is on you.
>> Rebecca, I know you're
my best friend
and you've had breast cancer.
I just really need you
to come with me
and we can get this done.
You're awesome.
I know it's gonna be difficult.
We've had a lot
of ups and downs together.
I can be your manager.
I can bring you back.
I can really help you.
You're a survivor.
We can do this show!
It's gonna be called
"The Bubble."
And we're gonna have
lots of awesome actors in it!
>> Encouraging.
Bravo!
Encouraging.
We'll be right back with more